wouldn't you know it we solved a Twitter
mystery well it turns out if you believe
the left and the never Trump errs Donald
Trump himself may well have taken
possession of Roseanne Bars account and
tapped out the tweet that led to the
demise of her hit sitcom in her entire
career now listen closely all roads lead
back to Trump we know what Donald Trump
thinks we know what Roseanne Barr thinks
it's time for us to stop playing around
with soft words by saying oh well
they're saying insensitive things no
it's racist they're exhibiting racist
behavior I'm not someone that has Trump
derangement syndrome and blames Donald
Trump for everything but this right here
this kind of stuff is a direct byproduct
of how Donald Trump behaves the thing
that sort of is the background of all of
this is that the president can be racist
and nothing happens to him so now they
do believe in guilt by association huh
well they didn't subscribe to that
belief when this happened
[Music]
[Music]
even though President Obama sat in
Jeremiah Wright's pews for years
marinating in that hate well we were
told that Wright's comments were not
representative of Obama's own beliefs
well this despite the fact that unlike
Trump and Roseanne the Obamas were close
to right they were a little tight he was
a president spiritual mentor for years
and who can forget this 2005 gem that
was conveniently hidden from public view
by the photographer for years oh that's
a beauty
well we never saw that pic until Obama
left office well you see the left
protects and defends their own because
they're immune to criticism for their
unsavory political associations but the
president calls an actress and
congratulate her for her rating success
and suddenly he's responsible for
everything she's ever done or will do
when you have a president that started
his political career on birtherism
saying that he's not one of us when he's
dead everything he could to do dog
whistling around this issue of race
people like worlds and feel they're
empowered what a fraud this is the man
who brought us the fake Tawana Brawley
case the man who defended the claims of
the lying Duke Lacrosse accuser when he
wasn't of course evading taxes or
shaking down corporations and this is
who MSNBC wheels out as an expert
Sharpton on bigotry and civility in
America please the left has to tag
Roseanne's racial misdeed to Trump why
well because they have no substantive
answers to the problems facing minority
communities today so their only recourse
is to do what they do best race bait and
demonize their opponents meanwhile
Trump is actually delivering undeniable
results we know unemployment among
blacks and Hispanics is down to historic
lows we know he's trying to rid their
communities of gangs like ms-13 and the
president is now even working with
Congress to pass prison reform we'll get
into a little bit that later on all of
this has caused his support to grow
among minority groups modest gains but
the left of course refuses to applaud
any of Trump's progress or work with him
even on issues where they have common
ground
that's how fanatical they are instead
what the left does is they plot they
plot away on how to exploit the next
moment of racial outrage here is how
Hoover Institution Fellow and phenomenal
author Shelby Steele who actually lived
through segregation in the south how he
sees it from today on my radio show it's
amazing to me that the amount of
creativity and imagination that goes
into some reinventing racism
visualization is power and it's money
and this isn't these are people who are
pursuing not you know a race free world
a great a world free of racism but these
are people who are pursuing wealth
they're the racial entrepreneurs they're
going to make careers out of this much
of the black middle class today sadly is
supported by
through diversity work and programs
again that's from an african-american
man who lived through real racism
suffered through segregation his
comments
well people of course read Roseanne's
tweet as racially biased and it's
totally understandable she herself said
it was indefensible but there are other
forms of bias routinely expressed by the
left that stereotyped and malign good
and hardworking Americans every day
remember the women who voted for Trump
in light of this last election I'm
concerned about us as women and how we
think that's on us I know that comments
are how their husbands write tells us
what to do really a black rapper who
supports Trump different celebrities
desperate for attention and finding ways
whether it's positive or negative to get
it now his wife is tweeting back at
people basically saying don't be too
hard on my husband don't necessarily
make it seem like he's going through
some sort of mental breakdown which we
know he's had mental health problems we
have the right to independent thoughts
and I independently think that Kanye has
lost his mind
traditional Christians one thing to talk
to Jesus it's another thing when Jesus
talks to you exactly
[Applause]
illness if I'm not correct we're
basically talking pretty much about any
and all Trump supporters you could put
half of Trump supporters into what I
call the basket of deplorable z-- well
think about it this other way if Trump
created a safe space for Roseanne to
write this inflammatory tweet as the
left is saying well maybe with that
deplorable z' comment Hillary Clinton
inspired this tens of millions of people
voted for him after he showed his cards
four years
what are you said we are you suggesting
that they're racist right there yes oh
they're deplorable 'he's after all
roseanne has now been excommunicated
from the public square for comments that
ABC rightfully characterized as a
pourraient repugnant and inconsistent
with our values my question is when will
the day of reckoning come for those on
the left whose own opponent and
repugnant views are inconsistent with
our values and that's the angle